Frederick Douglass he had this great
quote I shall always unite with those
who do good but I shall not unite with
those who do wrong I wish this person
could be alive today to be an example of
what kids can be and do if they have the
drive to conceive of a dream and the
guts and the strengths and the
motivation to achieve that dream we want
to be part of the resources that help
them receive that dream and that's my
biggest hope I think that to invest in
kids that can become great from
Hillsdale is really to invest in the
future of our country you know my
grandparents were tremendously
philanthropic he talked about the
importance of helping and others that
can't otherwise afford to do things that
are important the emphasis in my
father's teaching was invest in other
people don't just keep it all for
yourself
my specialty is working with terminally
ill adults and children and grief
therapy I actually was led to that
because when I was 13 years old I was
diagnosed with muscular dystrophy
there's a misdiagnosis I was in a
wheelchair and effectively blind because
my muscles were not strong enough to see
straight forward came to Detroit and
there it was found that I was
misdiagnosed so I felt I had gotten my
life back and I'm confident that that
had a great deal of influence on my
direction I love my private practice
people asked me how can I hold somebody
in
when they die and say I could never do
that I could never be an accountant I do
believe that my experience as a child
understanding that I was not going to be
living very long has really helped me to
become very comfortable helping others
to die into Michigan when I had my first
call from McCormick Theological Seminary
I met Bonnie there and she claims that I
promised her a ticket to heaven the
truth I'm the one that got that ticket I
think because we married 34 years and
I'm married to my best friend and I'm
still stupidly in love with her so it's
cool
bonnie is an alum daughter Hillary when
tails dealt if she got a degree in
psychology and now she is working in
philanthropic work as well the thing
that makes Hillsdale Hillsdale hire the
students that aspire to go there and to
do great things that's really what what
our interest has been is hopefully to
support students especially those that
otherwise couldn't afford to go there if
love Hillsdale College I think that
school is one of the most amazing
resources in America I've always told my
wife I've gone and I wish I had
graduated from this school
you